a black sea villa
still under construction it's believed
the house belonged to the Yanukovych
family a symbol of the luxury he and his
inner circle enjoyed the country he
ruled is facing economic collapse
Russian banks that were Ukraine's
traditional backers have halted new
loans Russia's second biggest lender VTB
says it already has four hundred million
euros of exposure in Ukraine President
Vladimir Putin says his country has
invested a total of twenty billion euros
in its Western neighbor inside Ukraine
people are emptying their accounts in
fear that the country's banks could
collapse the overall economy is anemic
at best in the wake of the global
financial crisis in 2009 the economy
contracted dramatically it recouped some
of the loss but more recently has
stagnated analysts believe 2013 growth
came in at just not 0.4% on Thursday
Ukraine's new leadership asked the
International Monetary Fund for help
the IMF will be sending a team to Kiev
next week to assess the situation
there's not much time to lose